in Hungary
we were able to unify these forces
through the lands of of of of nation so
if you love your country it doesn't
matter whether you are a classical
liberal libertarian or religious
conservatives and then then then this is
the point where where you have to be
United and and you have to be able to
use your resources
um against your political opponents
because they are using everything what
they have the institutions the state
transnational organizations media
Academia
and and until that moment uh we on this
side were just just you know just too
silent
and too fragmented
on Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
from the local studio right here in
Miami and joining me today is the
political director for the prime
minister of Hungary Paula shorben
welcome to the Reuben report hi thank
you very much for inviting me I am glad
to have you here a freedom fighter from
across the way here in America in the
Free State of Florida uh I was trying to
think how I wanted to do this interview
because I will be very honest up top I
don't think Americans know much if
anything about Hungary and I am not
going to pretend to be a hungry expert
so I thought the best way we could start
this was a little hungry 101 if I say to
you tell me about Hungary what does that
mean to you
um I think all the people of United
States and Florida would love Hungary
because it's a small but old uh central
European country with a thousand years
old history
um as you were referred we
we are known in Europe as Freedom
Fighters because our history is about
constant fight for sovereignty we were
several times occupied by by foreigners
like the Ottomans like the hubsworths or
the austrians like the Nazi Germans and
the Russians and uh and uh and what we
survived and um right now we are proud
members of uh
um the European Union and the Western
Community
but we have our own values and we are
very proud of our nationhood our country
our traditions and
that's the reason I think why we came
part of the international debate at
least inside the western civilization
about the future of this civilization
which direction should we go
[Music]
if there is a dead end Street or not so
interestingly the guy that connected us
was my good friend pipa gozian who's
been on this show many many times who
you've met a few times now and he's in
Hungary right now and he is a or at
least was for most of his life a lefty
atheist but in search of freedom in
search of places where order exists and
Western values exist and he lives in
Portland where he's struggling to find
it there goes to Budapest and he's
finding it in Hungary that that's
interesting
he is a great guy
um and um and you know it's
currently we we at least those who are
working for the Hungarian government and
prime minister Orban we are
conservatives we are Christian democrats
we are obviously representing the
political right side out of question but
according to our understanding it means
freedom freedom speech freedom of
thinking freedom of expression and and
we have to preserve protect uh pluralism
in our society so if if Peter is there
uh and and he speaks openly about his uh
views we can we can argue we can debate
with him actually we are organizing
debates to show that these are the
Alternatives that let the people uh
choose and what he keeps telling to us
that it was the case in United States it
was the case in some of the Western
European countries but uh but currently
this is not the case anymore leftist
ideology is just um the one it wants to
control everything they want 100 power
not the separation of power so we sent a
small central European conservatives we
are trying to
um manage a political Refugee program
for for for people like uh peterborg and
interestingly uh most of my audience
will get it you're you then are called
all of the worst things right you're a
fashionist you're a bigot and all right
I should mention that although your last
name is Orban you are not related to the
Prime Minister Victor no correct that
must that must get very messy no and
it's not the case that you have to
change your name to Urban if you want to
go to politics and hungers yeah so okay
so you talked about the the values of
Hungary so so what do you think those
values are ever since uh from the way
you described it but what what broadly
do you think those values are
um I just came from the conference of
national conservativism I think this is
this is a movement which is an
intellectual movement which is uh very
close to our thinking and the basic
pillar of this movement is uh is um is
the idea of nation
so
we all know that we are in the era of
globalization and
um and and and time will not uh change
so we have to adapt to that situation
but but but I think the the challenges
of the uh previous decades like like the
pandemic like the economic crisis like
the migration crisis what we are also uh
facing in Hungary they prove that the
the nation as a concept is is the only
form which can serve the interest of of
the citizens and of the community who
are living under the rule of that
destination so so everybody is talking
about uh globally globalized
cooperational International
organizations but but
and if there is sunshine and if there is
trade between the Nations I can imagine
that it can do good things
um for the people but but if there is
trouble if there is um
um wind and and bad weather then you you
can only go back to your to your to your
nation to your own government they had
they should be responsible for uh for
you uh and and for for the people who
are uh part of that uh community so this
is the basic idea uh unfortunately it's
not very trendy or mainstream right
we're working on it we're working we're
working on it and um
and and you know it's not easy to talk
about uh God and and and and religion
because uh because that's a personal
matter but but but still we do think
that these um God and the idea of
religion and and tradition and and the
teaching with which comes from from the
Bible through for example Christian
Democratic political philosophy it has
to
play a very important role
um in in in buildings a well-functioning
society even in the 21st century so I
spoke at a couple panels and and gave a
talk at netcon last year and that was
one of the main things that came up that
how do you blend as as wokeness sort of
infects all the Western institutions and
governments
if the return is to be something of a
return with some level of religiosity in
it what do you do about the people
outside of that either the non-believers
or the gay people or just anyone that is
not within say sort of the Christian
tradition as you would see it and I know
this is a big debate no no no it's a
it's a huge debate but according to our
understanding probably it's a it's um
it's it's different here in the United
States or even in Poland
a country which is very close to us in
Europe so so we are not focusing on the
on the individual
uh belief of the people because
um it's a freedom of decision if you
want to uh be on board if you want to
take it if you want to be a believer if
you want to be an active churchgoer you
can do so
um you are not allowed to be punished
for that but if you don't want to do it
then it's fine but the but the but the
ideas the political ideas who are which
are coming from this this kind of uh
concept they are
um they are useful like like
you know uh family is a basic pillar of
society family is is based on the idea
of a marriage between a man and woman
and and and one of the most important
goal of this kind of marriage is to
raise children and those children will
be the next generation without those
children there is no Community anymore
so it's not uh about the individual
decision whether you are homosexual or
heterosexual whether you are
um you want to have one children or two
or three it's it's about that from a
society perspective the more the state
can do for those who are ready to go
into a marriage between a man and woman
and ready to take as many children as
they want
then the state's role is to support them
through State institutions so what is
the idea so one of the things that
you've been doing is encouraging people
to have kids because you wrote a piece
recently I mean you're worried about
sort of population collapse which
everyone you know if you listen to
mainstream media it's basically that the
Earth is going to be overrun with humans
we're going to have no resources left
and there's too many of us and if
everyone could have less kids that would
be good and uh you see it I think it's
just yeah I think it's just the uh other
way around so and especially you know we
hungarians we are we are a small nation
just 10 million people so probably for
big Empires the perspective the
historical perspective is a bit
different but for us
um we think that we have a very unique
culture we have a unique language
culture we are an island in Europe we
want to preserve it and we need
um people and we need children who are
ready to uh to be the representatives of
this uh culture in the future if we
don't have these people then everything
what is linked to to hungarian-ness will
disappear and we don't we don't want to
let it happen so so we need people so it
sounds like you're fighting in many ways
the same
the same sort of wokeness the same sort
of top-down thing that it's a little
hard to tell where it's coming from but
corporations and and globalists and all
this stuff when did it start in Hungary
or where did it start like how how
powerful is it like is it is it sort of
like America where now it's in all of
our TV shows it's on the news all the
time our corporations are part of it is
it a similar feeling there so
um the Vogue avocism and gender ideology
it's a it's a brand new issue in in
Hungary and it uh it it came
through the channel through the
transatlantic channel so obviously it
came from unfortunately from the United
States but the hungarians you know we
were occupied by the Russians
um uh like 40 years and and through this
period of occupation uh the Russians
they did try to teach us to Marxist
ideologies and constantly in school in
universities everybody was repeating the
the the nonsense Marxist ideas so so in
in an average Hungarian or aggressive
Hungarian voter they are resistant
against this
Marxist they were resistant again
actually against the Marxist propaganda
and when the woke came in they
immediately realized that there is a
connection between the origin of marxist
ideology and and the Vogue or the gender
ideology it's a it's a it's a Neo
Marxist how is it coming in though
coming in through television that was
imported or movies
yeah culture and um and and ngos uh
media and ngos they are playing a very
important role first was uh
whether the soccer players should go
down to their knee right or or not and
um you know we wait so you had your own
version of that relative to the
Hungarian uh no actually we were we were
through International media forced to
follow the this thing and and you know
we were saying that that look we
understand that some of them are I know
it's controversial issue here in the
United States as well but uh but I
understand that some of the people are
saying that it's about racial equality
which is important but uh but uh and
about the black communities but we
didn't have any slavery in Hungary we
don't have any better community so this
is a cultural reference point which is
which is not ours so it's not a problem
if somebody else is doing that but if we
are forced to do so and forced to follow
then it's uh it's it's it's it's it's
it's it's something scary
and then
a couple months later
the the educational issues came in and
ngos and media people they started to
launch campaigns in schools
um
you know
how how to make it easier for children
to to change their sex and and they
question their identity the whole lgbtq
movement came in and then we realized
that this is serious so we accepted the
legislation quite similar to the Florida
one to protect the miners and and ban
sexual
orientation classes without the consent
of the parents
and we were immediately attacked by by
the headquarter of the European Union by
Nebraska and bureaucrats
and then we made the decision that you
know our only chance is
this is common sense what we are saying
and and it will be backed by the people
so we we launched a referendum and in
this April we had a referendum on this
gender ideological issues four questions
and the hungarians uh said with an
overwhelming majority 92 percent of the
votes and the turnout was was was the
biggest in the history of referendum of
modern uh Hungary so more people
participated in the referendum than in a
migration issue than in a NATO
enlargement issue or EU enlargement
issue and they voted
um with a huge majority against
these gender ideological things and it's
a huge success but uh but where does
your media fit in that I mean was the
media doing what our media does which is
here in Florida you know calling Ron
DeSantis a homophone yeah I mean it's is
do you see it as a very similar yeah
it's it's a very similar pattern but the
the only difference is
not only the domestic media but the
international media is is on us as well
and it makes very hard to survive but
but we have
no other chance once we are supported by
the people so we don't have to be
popular in the editorial board of the
New York Times we have to be popular
among the Hungarian voters we have to
represent their ideas and second
if the western civilization goes forward
to that direction that's going to be a
suicide mission yeah so somehow we
should turn
turn back or turn away from this
direction and and to do so you have to
stand up and be outspoken even if it's
controversial you mentioned right before
we started we spoke only for just two or
three minutes before we started but you
said something about how the the other
uh European nations that there's very
few people in the Nations willing to
stand up for their own Nations and and
that seems to be the fight that that you
guys have who else is kind of doing it
right are there is there anyone else
Poland seems to maybe have a version of
this that's working
and that's true Poland is a strong
country four times bigger than than
Hungary it plays a very important
role they have a clear conservative
government they have a very
tough nation-state tuition that they and
they are doing great economically very
successful
and there are actually there are
everywhere political forces who are
representing the same ideas the only
problem is that the establishment is
doing is doing everything which is what
is necessary to not let them
let them in
um there will be election in um in um in
Italy end of this month and the Italian
bright side is doing doing great the
Coalition of right-wing parties they are
leading in a polls so it would be a it
can be a game changer so in this piece
that I read that you laid out so we
talked about the population portion of
it and why you want obviously people to
have kids and multiply and that and you
know the the topic migration is linked
to that so that that was the next one I
was yeah yeah sorry because it's linked
to uh it's linked to the idea of
population decline if if we can agree on
on on that we need people
then some of the Liberals are saying
that okay from a labor market point of
view I agree with you just open up and
just open up but then um then you lose
everything what makes you what you are
because those people who are coming
there obviously coming from uh
from different civilizational they are
bringing in different civilizational
backgrounds what's been the general uh
immigration policy of Hungary say over
the last decade or two what's the
general if you if you want to come in or
with the migrants and the presidents you
guys are under yeah so so deep uh the
the general approach is it's it's very
simple we have experience
um neighboring countries
um ethnic hungarians or uh those people
who are belonging to to neighboring
Nations they they are trying to come
trying to come to Hungary illegally uh
we make it possible illegally we
uh don't support that idea and and
currently we are hosting more than uh
one million Ukrainian refugees they are
our neighbors so uh so we have the
humanitarian responsibility for help
them uh but what we experienced in 2015
that was the first time that
something is happening and it's totally
different than than what we experienced
before 400
000 illegal migrants came to our
Southern borders and they wanted to just
come in and cross the border without any
permission and they just wanted to go to
Germany some of them wanted to stay but
many of them wanted to go to Germany
Sweden and other other countries and and
this was a point when prime minister
Orban realized that that
you know the migration what we were
talking about it's completely different
uh from what we will experience in these
debates and and if we look around
um sub-Saharan Africa North Africa uh
Middle East Central Asia there are
millions of millions of people 10
millions and 10 millions of people
coming from overpopulated countries uh
and and they want to start a new life
somewhere and Europe that's the closest
uh continent so they want to start
without any permission they started they
want to start a new life in in Europe so
what was that like in 2015 I mean
everyone remembers the videos of just
watching people now we see these videos
now from Mexico into the United States
pretty much the same but so in essence
disorder it seemingly kind of happened
overnight it was really obviously
related to the war in Syria and
everything but what did you stop people
immediately do you like how yeah how
quickly the tricky thing was was that
the left was saying that that it's
mainly linked to the war in Syria so
it's a local conflict issue but uh but
we hosted people on our certain borders
from they were coming from more than 100
countries so not just Syria it was just
back at that time it was just 30 40
percent uh it's it's it's a more broader
issue and we we mean we immediately
realized that if um our country is not
able to protect the borders and to
restore Law and Order then then we are
lost and and we established the fans we
built the Border fans it was a three
months operation
um and around
150 miles
um and and we stopped them and we
introduced the border control measures
where we stop everybody who is not have
the right to to enter and we get
threatened by the EU of course of course
since then that's a constant legal Court
War right
um right so what do they try to do I
mean they try to force you to just let
anyone in or what what are their
punishments really
um there were several uh punishment uh
the the latest is that they are
attacking us through the course so they
are
um in charge of the court system and
then the institutions and and they try
to block over our legal mechanisms to
um to stop the people because the idea
is is that
that
if you are an illegal immigrant you are
not allowed to enter the country and
walk freely you have to apply for Asylum
and until the decision is made you are
not allowed to enter the territory of
the country because then you're gonna
disappear and
it will be impossible to find you
um and so and this is the basic idea of
what which according to their
understanding goes against
um the
humanitarian law requirements but it's
nonsense those humanitarian legal
requirements were out those are outdated
those are those are historical memories
um based on the Geneva Convention from
1951 back at that time the thing was
very different do you think they don't
even know what they're calling for or do
you think it is more nefarious than that
when you when you see this coming in
either through the ideas of wokeness or
quite literally the people walking
across the borders
no I think it's um it's it's it's a
political program of the left
and political program of of George
harosh and his open Society Foundation
because they think that European nations
they are they are threats of the future
so what they want to do is to
deconstruct these nations and how can
you deconstruct a nation so change you
have to change the population you have
to
um
let people in who are coming from uh
different civilization and give them
citizenship as as soon as it is possible
they are not Christians they are mainly
Muslims they are they don't share our
values they have their own value system
they are very proud of it
um and and I don't want to judge this
kind of value system probably it works
in in Muslim societies
um or it definitely works in Muslim
societies but ours in our society where
the value system is is different so it's
it's I think and and those people if
they come in and they settle they they
establish parallel societies immediately
and they are supporting leftist liberal
political forces with a huge majority so
for them it's a political program to
destroy the old European type of nation
states when when you talk to your
counterparts either in Germany or in the
UK places that let tons of people in
that have these parallel societies do
they go man we're jealous you guys are a
little ahead of us on this thing we we
missed it
according to our understanding this is a
mistake what you can
what you can have only once
and if you you make that mistake and you
let millions of millions of people in
and you give them citizenship then it's
over
because
um
because
um because because you have no other
chance you have to lift it uh with the
with those people and what our
counterparts are saying that um look you
are right
but uh our situation is different I have
to uh at least try to convince those
voters so I cannot cannot be the
defender of the Christian civilization
um if um 20 or 15 percent of my voters
are coming from a different background
so most probably you are right most
probably we made a bad decision we were
because we were only looking
to The Economic Consequences of decision
not the culture consequences but but
that's it so that's why we hungarians we
have to be and prime minister of urban
is in the sense the the most tough
anti-migration politician in in Europe
because because we have to be very tough
on on that issue once you commit this
mistake these people are in they are
part of society and the whole
equilibrium is changing so you mentioned
the Prime Minister and I know that he
was either was or is friendly with our
former prime minister Donald Trump and
obviously a lot of things you're talking
about in terms of borders and culture
and things like that sound sort of
trumpian
um was that a was that a nice little
time for you guys when there was sort of
similar leadership in the United States
that I suspect is a little bit different
right now yeah that's that's uh that's
true
um honestly in domestic politics we are
we are the strongest so we've won four
consecutive term with two third majority
so people are on our side but but but
what does that mean in terms of the vote
like so what percentage of the vote
roughly is that
um more than 50 yeah more than 50 and
um and uh which is our system it differs
from your system it's not the two-party
system so so in a European context
that's huge yeah
um and uh
um but internationally inside the
Western Hemisphere the situation is not
not so good so so
um for example in 2016 when President
Trump came into Power Benjamin Netanyahu
was the Prime Minister in Israel
um
brexiters were were emerging in in
London
uh we had Angela Merkel that was a
Christian Democrat Coalition based but
still Christian Democrat
um government we had because she did let
a lot of migrants in which probably yeah
yeah yeah yeah but
um but but right now in the Ukrainian
issue
um we would need
um a European leadership of the Germans
and we don't have this kind of
leadership so so we had a huge conflicts
with her but uh but she is missing right
now not because of the migration because
of the geopolitical issues
um so so back at the time International
cooperation was easier but
um but but I think better days should
come the polls are on board Italy there
will be a
changing of the government I hope United
States in the United States during the
midterm election the Republicans will do
a good job
uh and uh and the economic situation in
Europe it's um it's it's it's very hard
so Energy prices are skyrocketing and
middle class is suffering
um serious problems and all the
countries are governed by by uh by left
in government so I think we will have a
very turbulent political time is it is
it crazy to you or obvious that so many
of the nations are going through this at
the exact same time I mean almost
everything you're laying out here to
some degree is pretty much what's
happening here and it's pretty much
what's happening in the UK and and all
over the place and I guess that's the
point right we are connected by Design
yeah we are connected and you know for
for
I think for for the Liberals
uh it's very very easy intellectually to
cooperate on an international level
because if you are a liberal it means
that that you have your principles your
value system and it's Universal it
doesn't matter where you are it doesn't
matter where you are in DC in um I don't
know Scandinavia in Africa in even in in
Southeast Asia if you are a liberal then
you have your values and you want to
turn the government into that direction
and you have no conflict with the others
who are liberals but living on the other
side of the world but but for the
conservatives or or or in a positive way
nationalists it's it's hard because uh
all your beliefs are coming from from
from the history of your nation so it's
a historically
sociologically geographically it's based
and it differs from the views of of of
other of others
um and and that's the reason why
cooperation is very hard because we will
never agree 100 on on uh on on
everything because because you are
following the interest of your nation
and I am following the interest of my
nation but through mutual respect and
understanding I think this kind of
cooperation if you are able to
um
um
to make these connections then then in
the long term they can be stronger
because uh because it's rational and and
based on mutual respect which is always
a good starting point but it's a tough
experiment right I mean this is this is
what they're trying to figure out can
you take ex-libs and Libertarians mix
them with these religious conservatives
all fight wokeism and it seems to me
that everyone sort of right now is kind
of willing to put their swords down to
make it work but the question is okay if
we make it work what happens after that
yeah
I don't have the answer the only thing I
know is uh if you know the I hope we get
to see because then we'll have at least
defeated yeah yeah yeah yeah sure but
you know if
so in in
Hungary uh we were able to unify these
forces uh through the lands of of of of
of nation so if you love your country it
doesn't matter whether you are a
classical liberal libertarian or
religious conservatives and then then
then this is the point where where you
have to be United and and you have to be
able to use your resources
um against your political opponents
because they are using everything what
they have the institutions the state
transnational organizations media
Academia
and and and until that moment uh we on
this side were just just you know just
too silent
and too fragmented so we talked about a
little bit related to migration but okay
so Ukraine now how many uh companies do
you say one one million one million that
are to be settled to become uh citizens
or no under their own they um they they
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's
huge they left um uh Ukraine and they
came to Hungary we managed an operation
to host them and help them some of them
went back some of them went uh to other
European countries but some of them stay
so what is hungary's position on what's
going on there you know and I'll say
that to the backdrop of I haven't
covered Ukraine much on my show because
I've found it's extremely difficult
getting an honest assessment of what's
going on and who really are the good
guys and the bad guys and everything
else it's just it's just been very messy
yeah so
according to our understanding
um and I also live in a country that's
halfway across yeah yeah not right there
yeah yeah yeah sure it's it's not your
problem yeah but it is but it is because
all of these things are interesting
because of the prizes and so on yeah
it's true so
um I think it's out of question that the
Russians are are the aggressors in in
that story of course and and and the
ukrainians are are brave and they are uh
protecting their uh country and we
should help them uh but um
but it's a question of peace and
prolongation of War so what we are doing
right now the westerners together that's
the NATO strategy let's call it yeah
that way that we support through
military
equipments weapons and so on the
ukrainians and they are fighting and
they are doing good but but but the war
is still there and it's gonna stay there
for a long time
and the
and the consequences of the war
they are destroying uh our economies
um mainly through the energy sanctions
and um and um can you describe how that
directly affects you guys so the U.S or
NATO put sanctions on Russia and then
you fear of energy and it brings up the
prices immediately because if you are
not allowed some some countries are not
allowed to to buy
um Russian gas or oil it means that you
know it's it's like a a trade market so
immediately the prices are getting
higher and higher and you have to buy
the energy from somehow because Europe
is uh is not independent right
um and um and you know if the energy
prices are high then it immediately
causing inflation and it it is causing
serious trouble for manufacturing uh
companies if they close then people are
losing their jobs so it's a process it's
it's a it's a rational economical
process which is going on
so according to our understanding
this war should be stopped but not
stopped through escalation or
prolongation of the war but through
peace talks so our position is that we
should
I'm in the west and and obviously the
United States should be involved with
the because the Russians they take only
seriously the United States so there
should be Russian U.S peace talks and
which we would need immediate ceasefire
and and and and try to cool down
um the process is there even any talk of
that right now no yeah unfortunately not
so so what do you make of that
fortunately not because uh because the I
I think the American position is that uh
this kind of prolongation of War it
weakens Russia for sure
uh the ukrainians are willing to do so
uh
and the Europeans are not strong enough
to represent their own interest in that
situation I'm mainly talking about
friends and and Germany but there's no
real credible threat behind them if they
were to come to the table with Russia uh
yeah but I'm I mean
I mean you know they are politically
also fragile so Coalition of government
uh the the different parties they have a
different opinion on on that
um the international mainstream is is
very hard on putting pressure on those
who are saying that look it shouldn't be
a war propaganda around this issue but
but but the other we should do the other
way around the peace propaganda should
be uh started and spread everywhere uh
but uh but we are not close to that but
unfortunately
um
the winter will be very hard and I hope
that sooner or later everybody will
realize that the prolongation of War
it's it's just not not a good way what
do you think the off-ramp looks like for
Russia what what's something that they
can sit down and say okay we got this we
can end this thing now
no I can I can have my own opinion uh
the Hungarian leadership can have
its own opinion but but we are not a
game changer in this situation so so it
should be done by the big players we are
just a small Mouse in the room there are
big elephants in the room they should
make their own decisions but the problem
is that currently nobody as you
mentioned nobody is talking about these
kind of peace talks yeah everybody is
talking about that you know we should
keep going we should go further uh what
is happening there and and you know the
the ukrainians made they made a just
just recently a good uh counter Star
Strike but then the Russians made the
Counter-Strike
the whole story is is is from a
humanitarian point of view it's it's
getting even worse and worse and worse
and we should stop that yeah so I wasn't
even planning on mentioning this to you
but I just would sort of sits with all
of this is you know we have a major
censorship problem here in the United
States and a completely I would say it
like a media that is in complete
dereliction of their duties and deeply
dishonest and not friendly to a lot of
the ideas that we're discussing here so
I'm curious on two things sort of how is
your media generally and and what about
censorship and what's going on with the
internet and big Tech and all those
things how much of that is an important
part of your world
no it's a very important part uh and
from our perspective media it's a
sovereign issue again so if media is
owned by foreigners then foreigners are
dictating what the hungarians should
think so it's uh the first and for most
important point is that uh
at least the majority of the Hungarian
media should be owned by hungarians it
doesn't matter whether they are liberals
conservative socialists what ideology
they have but it should be in the hand
of hungarians in that sense we are
um we are in a much better shape than
than we were 12 years ago when the urban
government came into Power the the other
thing is is that pluralism is important
so the the variety of opinions should be
visible
and and people Hungarian people should
make their own decision which which um
opinions they they want to follow
um and in this sense I think the
Hungarian media is a better shape than
than the media in um in Western Europe
because the balance between
so-called it's obviously oversimplifying
the things but the liberal views and the
conservative views or or the progressive
liberal views and the conservative uses
it's quite balanced so it's 50 50.
interesting so you're and and do you
find you have counterparts on say the
progressive liberal side that you can
debate publicly or or get into these
conversations with because that's what's
going on here that's very difficult is
they they don't seem to want to debate
anymore or even have these conversations
yeah
um that's a good question some sometimes
they they are on board with the debate
and and they are available but but then
they make a decision if their interest
is is that and they close down
everything and they are not
communicating well because to be clear I
would whoever might be the counterpart I
know you don't have a counterpart on the
Progressive side because there's no
they're not in the government right now
but I would have that person on and yeah
treat them the exact same way but I
suspect after talking to someone with
the last name Orban that's probably not
gonna happen yeah yeah but but you know
I I think it's important and and we
conservatives are the Hungarian right
side we we are confident because we
think that that the truth is on our side
so I am confident that I can win all the
debates
um so
um I'm I'm always ready to to to discuss
these things but but their mindset is a
bit uh different you mentioned the big
tech companies uh they are playing an
even more and more important role in
Hungarian public sphere
and and the censorship is obviously an
issue there as well the our situation is
even worse than your situation because
uh because those tech companies are are
uh their headquarter is in the United
States or in another European country so
we don't have those companies so what
was done by
um for example Governor DeSantis that
through taxation and through some
legislative actions
um
he he wanted to
create a fair treatment for all the
political opinions yeah we hungarians
and the other small central European
countries we are uh we we are I'm not
saying we are we are too less but but we
don't have as much tools as as you have
here in the United States that's why for
us it's it's it's important that that
the Republicans are are pushing this
thing forward because because otherwise
it it will have an effect on the other
uh European
um uh countries what level of censorship
do you guys think you're dealing with
it's almost impossible to tell because
once you're being censored and throttled
and all the things you don't know but
you know I would I would imagine if uh
if the Prime Minister was to put out
something that they could even frame as
anti-immigrant and I've read a lot of
his speeches where they go completely
insane call them racist and all these
things and if you read it it's actually
quite measured and sort of what you've
laid out here so can you even tell what
level of censorship you're dealing with
um it's not as bad as it happened in the
United States that the one platform
banned the the president and then
everyone bad yeah and then everyone
banned uh the president so it's just um
it it did not happen yet
um uh but uh but but my experience as
well as a politician and some other
politicians also
um experience that and we have we know
that those people who are in charge of
making these kind of decisions they are
not accountable uh but uh but we know
them and um and and from an ideological
perspective they are not their opinion
is obviously not balanced and um and
you know making these kind of decisions
shouldn't be made by private companies
it's so simple and it's not a brand new
issue it wasn't invented this this
thought just recently it's it's it's uh
it's well known for like centuries and
and thousands and thousands of years
that that these kind of decisions should
be made by independent uh branches
that's why uh we invented the idea of
independent judiciary
and and currently the the the role of
the independent Judiciary is done by
these uh private companies censorship
group of people
I think it's nonsense but but I'm quite
optimistic because uh because uh through
the the history of the technological
development but the all all the new
platforms were coming in first radio and
then the television and then the
internet and then right now the social
media so that was always at the
beginning a kind of a turbulent time
when the when the state made the
Takeover so it's just just it does not
mean that there should be State uh
censorship but but through legislative
power at least some Fair balance should
be immediately established and they did
in with the radio with the television
and with all the platforms just took
couple couple years right I mean I hope
it's gonna happen but when you say you
hope it's gonna happen do you mean from
an American side because these are
American companies for the most part
that you want something to happen on the
legislators yeah yeah yeah
I hate to tell you my friend I don't
think so or uh or at least
um in Europe uh because uh because
probably we hungarians we're just small
players in that issue but but Europe as
such as 27 countries so so this is
something which should be discussed on
the European level and and act uh we
should act together but until that
moment it did not happen
I normally don't end on a question like
this but is there is there anything else
that you want to hit on I think we I
think we hit most of the big stuff
you're here in town in Miami for the
national conservatism conference as we
talked about and that's ongoing for a
couple days and they're trying to hash
out all the things that we've discussed
did you hear anything else interesting
there that that is on your mind or
relevant to hungry or no or have you
been shocked by anything since you've
been here in the United States you know
worse than you thought is it better no
no no because all the Americans I know
and I like they are anti-voke and they
are very nice people and they are very
nice to to my country so yeah yeah you
should go to Portland and see what's
happening yeah yeah the situation is
different for sure but uh but I have to
say that um that um always I I come to
here
um I I become more optimistic I know
that uh that uh you are also serious
trouble but but if I keep talking with
people
um the the idea of of American greatness
um it emerges immediately and and and I
think at the end of the day uh you will
figure out something and and the only
thing I I keep telling them that look I
know that America is special I know that
uh then it's like an elephant
um and all the others are just smaller
animals around you even the Europeans
but but there are some small animals
some mouses and sometimes the small
animals the mouses also can help the
elephants to survive or so these kind of
alliances uh is can be beneficial for
women both parties that was a beautiful
ending however I did say to you right
before we started I said this is a
beautiful cover of a book the book is
the Hungary the Hungarian way of
strategy uh can you just tell the people
what this uh this elk on the front of
the book yeah it's it's um it's an elk
or a stag and the and the idea according
to Hungarian history the Hungarian
tribes seven tribes who occupied the
land where we are living more than 1 100
years ago they were LED uh by by this uh
special creature uh so so so she was she
was
she was the one who who was doing the
the lead
um and and and through this animal uh a
Transcendent power or God was was
leading leading the way and the idea of
the cover is that this this tag is still
here still with us so the future is uh
not so pessimistic for us
now that counts as an ending thank you
very much thank you very much appreciate
it if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our International
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell